all right so the Last of Us episode 2
ends in a big way that changes something
major about what happens to Tess this is
a big alteration for the show and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down why it was done and what
the scene signified if you don't want
any spoilers then this is your heads up
as we're going to be doing a deep dive
on the series in game to discuss what
originally happened and also what
happened in the episode itself if you're
enjoyed the video so far and you
unsubscribed and I hope this is the one
that gets you to join and with out of
the way let's dive into it
okay so in The Last of Us games things
played out pretty similar to how they do
in the show Joel pessinelli made their
way across Boston to meet it with some
fireflies and this was in order to drop
the ladder off on the way Tess Was
Bitten in a museum and she ended up
going out in a blaze of glory now where
the gaming show differ is that test died
in a gunfight with Federer during her
final few moments in the series though
the location is sworn by the infected
and Tess ends up blowing herself up
along with the horde Now The Last of Us
official podcast dived into why this was
carried out and in its series credit
Neil druckman and Craig Martin discussed
what originally happened in it it said
that Federer being out that way didn't
make much sense in the grand scheme of
things and the more I think about it the
more I agree now in the game you had a
scene where they were all caught outside
the wall and you ended up killing two
guards after they scanned Ellie the
alarm was then sounded and you snuck
through the surroundings taking out
those that got in your way this kind of
makes sense as to why fedra had offended
her against you as you'd murdered at
least two gods and making a run for it
in the show though Joel kills that one
God and he doesn't call it in and
possibly wasn't even found until the
next day Mazin also said that the qz's
operation wouldn't really need people to
run out and go hunting others for
example leukisi is basically a big wall
at spell to keep people out they patrol
around the area to make sure no one can
attack it but they wouldn't go out of
their way to chase people down that had
already left because they're no longer a
problem it's not worth risking soldiers
to go and get three people and with this
in mind it does make a lot of sense now
the reason why it was changed the
infected and not just a group of Bandits
was because the showrunners wanted us to
see them in a new light this was done
primarily to show how they are a hive
Network and how the fungus could reach
out to others in order to get them to
swarm an area this creates an idea of
community and the people behind the show
have brought up time and time again how
this series is actually about love not
gonna get too spoilery for what's gonna
happen at the end of the series but love
is very much the thing that drives Joel
to do both good and bad in episode
episode 1 his love for Sarah is what
pushed him to attempt to save her and
her death is also what hurt him so much
he's likely going to do something with
Ellie down the line that's based on a
selfish love and this will show how it
can be both a good and bad thing you
also have the episode with Bill and
Frank coming out that's due to explore
their relationship so we have this theme
constantly popping up this explains why
the kiss was done and in many ways it
was meant to show the infected welcoming
tests into their hive mind where they
basically rule the planet as one
Collective they said that they try to
show this almost in a welcoming way with
a kiss being something completely weird
and haunting it almost felt like a
tender moment rather than an attack Neil
druckman who directed the entry you all
to stay that he staged this in the same
way that you'd State your romantic scene
they wanted to shoot it in the most
beautiful way possible because then
there'd be this undercurrent that makes
it even more messed up you have two
characters making eye contact and slowly
getting closer and closer and closer
before this the infected themselves are
blurred out as well and and we have this
one slowly coming into Focus as he gets
an era we're going over it they said
there's a pot of Tess that's actually
giving up at this point but then another
side of her comes through in the end I I
found myself watching and re-watching
and going
is it bait because she's still flicking
the lighter or are we watching this
transition of her giving in and the
lighter is the last fight that it's that
she knows she's lost the lighter isn't
lighting she flicks slower and less
frequently you can see her giving up
and then in the last moment whatever
final bit of her that's still there is
saying try one more time and she gets it
but I love the way we did that because
it's underscoring again
the theme of love and the way love
functions because the fungus loves too
it makes more of itself that's what we
do when we love each other a lot of us
make more of ourselves that's how the
species is probably just do it too often
some of us do too often and there's this
sense that you know what we are may look
disgusting and the way we reproduce may
be horrifying and violated
but it is tender
when this man comes to her it's not
violent because she's not fighting if
she ran if she fought back
they would all they would take her apart
yeah but she's just standing there and
he very gently shares of himself
and it is it's very jungian it's very
upsetting anything penetrative is
disgusting and scary when you're dealing
with monsters and
it just I don't know there's something
so creepy and gross and Primal about it
and yet also weirdly like Neil said the
way especially the way he shot it
beautiful
so there's a lot of stuff going on in
that shot and that's why we wanted to do
it that's so much more interesting than
like fedra showed up and shot so this
moment was changed for a number of
reasons and with his explanation I think
it might actually work better when I was
first watching it I was taken a bit back
by the whole kiss thing but I do think
it's one of those haunting moments that
really adds a new dimension to the
infected in the podcast they said that
had tests run then they would have
sprinted after her to tear her apart
however because there's no struggle it
almost becomes a tender moment which
makes it infinitely more horrifying
there's also the connotations of assault
and them very much forcing tests to
become one with them that adds these
extra layers that really Elevate how
frightening it is think because of these
added Dimensions that it really improves
the scene and almost makes it like a
collective hive mind it's very much
about her losing her freedom and
Independence and in this final moment
she resists and Sparks up the lighter
throughout the show we of course have
the saying look for the like con
instantly popping up and that is very
much seen as something that will guide
and help characters so I think the
symbolism is important here I also heard
that they want to test in the group
originally but they're glad that she
blew herself up because there wasn't
mushroom so there wasn't Mushroom in the
group hey you haven't had enough
are they also sorry I can't help myself
now they also talked about the backstory
for tests that they were originally
gonna show the episode was gonna open
with a basement door and would hear
banging coming from the other side of it
eventually would be revealed that Tess's
husband and son got infected and though
she killed the former she couldn't do it
to the latter so she locked him in the
basement and Ellie very much represented
a second chance at saving the sun she
couldn't this happened in the case of
Sarah too and it's sort of like poetry
they rhyme anyway that's my thoughts on
why they change things and obviously I'd
love to hear yours make sure you comment
below and let me know and I definitely
recommend that you check out the last of
us podcasts on the HBO YouTube channel
and on Spotify and on Apple podcast
sounds like I'm plugging it I'm not
getting paid it's a great lesson so if
you're a fan definitely go check it out
if you haven't already now as a thank
you for sitting until this point in the
video guess what you can get entered
into a competition where we're giving
away wakanda forever to three
subscribers on the 15th of February all
you have to do to be with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe applications done and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the
video we pick the comments at random on
the 15th and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers good to me else to watch then
make sure you check out our episode 2
breakdown which will be linked on screen
right now loads of Easter eggs in it
loads of game differences loads of
things go ahead over there right after
this by the way thanks for sticking to
the video I've been Paul I'll see you
next time take care peace